when i was in the sixth grade i got into
a fight at school
it wasn't the first time i'd been in a
fight but it was the first time one
happened at school
it was with a boy who was about a foot
taller than me who was physically
stronger than me
and who'd been taunting me for weeks
one day in pe he stepped on my shoe and
refused to apologize
so filled with anger i grabbed him and i
threw him to the ground
i'd had some previous judo training
our fight lasted less than two minutes
but it was a perfect reflection of the
hurricane that was building inside of me
as a young survivor of sexual assault
and as a girl who was grappling with
abandonment and exposure to violence in
other spaces in my life
i was fighting him but i was also
fighting the men and boys that had
assaulted my body
and the culture that told me i had to be
silent about it
a teacher broke up the fight and my
principal called me in her office
but she didn't say monique what's wrong
with you
she gave me a moment to collect my
breath
and asked what happened
the educators working with me led with
empathy
they knew me they knew i loved to read
they knew i loved to draw
they knew i adored prince
and they used that information to help
me understand why
my actions and those of my classmates
were disruptive to the learning
community they were leading
they didn't place me on suspension they
didn't call the police
my fight didn't keep me from going to
school the next day
it didn't keep me from graduating it
didn't keep me from teaching
but unfortunately that's not a story
that's shared by many black girls in the
u.s and around the world today
we're living through a crisis in which
black girls are being disproportionately
pushed away from schools
not because of an imminent threat they
pose to the safety of a school
but because they're often experiencing
schools as locations for punishment
and marginalization that's something
that i hear
from black girls around the country
but it's not insurmountable we can shift
this narrative
let's start with some data according to
a national black women's justice
institute analysis of civil rights data
collected by the u.s department of
education
black girls are the only group of girls
who are over-represented along the
entire continuum of discipline in
schools
that doesn't mean that other girls
aren't experiencing exclusionary
discipline
and it doesn't mean that girls aren't
over-represented other girls aren't
over-represented at other parts along
that continuum
but black girls are the only group of
girls who are over-represented all along
the way
black girls are seven times more likely
than their
white counterparts to experience one or
more out-of-school suspensions
and they're nearly three times more
likely than their white and latinx
counterparts to
be referred to the juvenile court a
recent study by
the georgetown center on poverty and
inequality partially explained
why this disparity is taking place when
they confirmed that black girls
experience
a specific type of age compression where
they're seen as more adult-like
than their white peers among other
things the study found
that people perceive black girls to need
less nurturing
less protection to know more about sex
and to be more independent than their
white peers
the study also found that the perception
disparity begins when girls are as young
as five years old
and that this perception and the
disparity increases over time
and peaks when girls are between the
ages of 10 and 14.
this is not without consequence
believing that a girl is older than she
is can lead to harsher treatment
immediate censure when she makes a
mistake and victim blaming when she's
harmed
it can also lead a girl to think that
something is wrong with her
rather than the conditions in which she
finds herself
black girls are routinely seen as too
loud too aggressive
too angry too visible qualities that are
often measured in relation to non-black
girls
and which don't take into consideration
what's going on in this girl's life
or her cultural norms and it's not just
in the u.s
in south africa black girls at the
pretoria girls high school were
discouraged from attending school with
their hair in its natural state
without chemical processing what did
those girls do
they protested and it was a beautiful
thing to see the global community for
the most part
wrap its arms around girls as they stood
in their truths
but there were those who saw them as
disruptive largely because they dared to
ask the question
where can we be black if we can't be
black in africa
it's a good question around the world
black girls are grappling with this
question
and around the world black girls are
struggling to be seen
working to be free and fighting to be
included in the landscape of promise
that a safe space to learn provides
in the u.s little girls just past their
toddler years are being arrested in
classrooms for having a tantrum
middle school girls are being turned
away from school because of the way they
wear their hair
naturally or because of the way the
clothes fit their bodies
high school girls are experiencing
violence at the hands of police officers
in schools
where can black girls be black without
reprimand or punishment
and it's not just these incidents in my
work as a researcher and educator i've
had an opportunity to work with girls
like stacy
a girl who i profile in my book push out
who struggles
with her participation in violence
she bypasses the neuroscientific and
structural analyses
that science has to offer about how her
adverse childhood experiences
inform why she's participating in
violence and go straight to describing
herself as a problem child
largely because that's the language that
educators were using as they routinely
suspended her
but here's the thing disconnection and
the internalization of harm grows
stronger in isolation
so when girls get in trouble we
shouldn't be pushing them away we should
be bringing them in closer
education is a critical protective
factor against contact with the criminal
legal system
so we should be building out policies
and practices that keep girls connected
to their learning rather than pushing
them away from it
it's one of the reasons i like to say
that education
is freedom work when girls feel safe
they can learn when they don't feel safe
they fight they protest they argue
they flee they freeze
the human brain is wired to protect us
when we feel a threat
and so long as school feels like a
threat or part of the tapestry of harm
in a girl's life
she'll be inclined to resist but when
schools become locations for
healing they can also become locations
for learning
so what does this mean for a school to
become a location for healing
well for one thing it means that we have
to immediately discontinue the policies
and practices that target black girls
for their hairstyles address
[Music]
let's focus on how and what a girl
learns
rather than policing her body in ways
that facilitate rape culture
or punish children for the conditions in
which they were born
this is where parents and the community
of concerned adults can enter
this work start a conversation with the
school
and encourage them to address their
dress code and other conduct-related
policies as a collaborative project with
parents and students so as to
intentionally avoid bias and
discrimination
keep in mind though that some of the
practices that harm black girls most are
unwritten
so we have to continue to do the deep
internal work to address the biases
that inform how when and whether we see
black girls for who they actually are
or what we've been told they are
volunteer at a school and establish
culturally competent and gender
responsive discussion groups with black
girls
latinas indigenous girls and other
students who experience
marginalization in schools to give them
a safe space to process their identities
and experiences
in schools and if schools are to become
locations for healing
we have to remove police officers and
increase the number of counselors
in schools
[Applause]
[Music]
education is freedom work
and whatever our point of entry is we
all have to be freedom fighters
the good news is that there are schools
that are actively working to establish
themselves as locations for girls to see
themselves as sacred and loved
the columbus city prep school for girls
in columbus ohio is an example of this
they became an example the moment their
principal declared that they were no
longer going to punish girls for having
a bad attitude
in addition to building essentially what
they did is they built out a robust
continuum of alternatives to suspension
expulsion and arrest
in addition to establishing a
restorative justice program
they improved their student and teacher
relationships by ensuring that every
girl has at least one adult on campus
that she can go to when she's in a
moment of crisis
they built out spaces along the
corridors of the school and in
classrooms for girls to regroup if they
need a minute to do so
and they established an advisory program
that provides girls with an opportunity
to start
every single day with the promotion of
self-worth
communication skills and goal setting at
this school
they're trying to respond to a girl's
adverse childhood experiences rather
than ignore them
they bring them in closer they don't
push them away
and as a result their truancy and
suspension rates have improved
and girls are arriving at school
increasingly ready to learn because they
know the teachers their care about them
that matters schools that integrate the
arts and sports
into their curriculum or that are
building out transformative programming
such as
restorative justice mindfulness and
meditation are providing an opportunity
for girls
to repair their relationships with
others but also with themselves
responding to the lived complex and
historical trauma that our students face
requires all of us who believe in the
promise of children and adolescents
to build relationships learning
materials
human and financial resources and other
tools
that provide children with an
opportunity to heal
so that they can learn
our schools should be places where we
respond to our most
vulnerable girls as essential to the
creation of a positive school culture
our ability to see her promise should be
at its sharpest
when she's in the throes of poverty and
addiction when she's reeling from having
been sex trafficked or survived other
forms of violence
when she's at her loudest or her
quietest
we should be able to support her
intellectual and social emotional
well-being
whether her shorts reach her knees or
stop mid-thigh
or higher
it might seem like a tall order in a
world so deeply entrenched in the
politics of fear
to radically imagine schools as
locations where girls can heal and
thrive
but we have to be bold enough to set
this as our intention
if we commit to this notion of education
as freedom work
we can shift educational conditions so
that no girl
even the most vulnerable among us will
get pushed out of school
and that's a win for all of us thank you
[Applause]